bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8 il est
18 heures si vous nous rejoignez en
direct en ce 18 décembre et bonsoir à
valérie horrible comme chaque mardi nous
allons faire le point sur
l'environnement avec vous la chronique
de l'environnement dans une vingtaine de
minutes et cette question que faire des
vieilles cabines téléphoniques une tite
une bonne question oui c'est une bonne
question où le fric certaines de lire
donc bientôt des bibliothèques dans les
lycées c'est le concept biblioblog se
développer par la maison de l'europe et
en partenariat avec orange et nous
verrons tout cela avec nos invités tout
à l'heure de toutes petites
bibliothèques alors
à tout à l'heure valérie autre question
qui va nous intéresser ce soir
qu'attendre de la réforme de l'éducation
vincent peillon ministre a donné
quelques éléments de réponse ce matin
dans une interview donnée à libération
carte scolaire stricte rythme scolaire
allégé ce qu'en pensent les syndicats
d'enseignants le snuipp-fsu responsable
départemental est en plateau avec nous
ainsi que le directeur de l'école de la
deuxième chance à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous les
entendrons dans un instant le reste des
sujets qui vont être développées ce soir
dans le 7-8 de ce 18 décembre en images
la sécurité routière à quelques jours
des fêtes de fin d'année l'heure est à
la prévention notamment à l'intention
des plus jeunes la cible la lutte contre
les excès dus à l'alcool l'école de la
deuxième chance de trappes vient de
remettre une fois de plus des
certifications
de d'apprentissage nous en parlerons
dans un instant je vous le disais
l'établissement qui accueille des jeunes
sortis du milieu scolaire affiche des
résultats encourageants à l'issue de
leur formation 70 % d'entre eux trouvent
une solution les anciennes cabines
téléphoniques ont une deuxième vie vous
allez le voir en images elles vont être
recyclés en bibliothèque de rue un
projet original développé notamment par
la maison de l'europe et puis il n'y a
pas d'âge pour commencer le basket une
initiation de baby basket était proposé
à guyancourt 112 jeunes issus de
quatorze clubs du département ont
participé une nouvelle présidente pour
le prêt ce peuple go l'université du
grand ouest parisien ce pôle de
recherche et d'enseignement supérieur
qui fédère plusieurs établissements dont
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines est nommée rectrice de dijon
sylvie faucheux a donc officiellement
laissé sa place une nouvelle directrice
vient d'être élue la présentation avec 4
x de la torre
une femme pour remplacer sylvie faucheux
à la tête de l'université paris-x grant
west anne sophie barthet vient d'être
nommée présidente du pôle de recherche
et d'enseignement supérieur de l'ue
bourgault qui regroupe notamment
l'université de versailles saint quentin
et l'université de cergy pontoise anne
sophie barthet et professeur agrégé de
droit privé depuis 2001 elle enseigne le
droit à l'université de cergy et depuis
mars 2012 elle est vice présidente en
charge du développement stratégique
anne sophie barthet cependant que la
succession de sylvie feucher ancienne
présidente nommé el rectrice de
l'académie de dijon dans ses projets
l'ouverture en 2013 de l'institut
d'études politiques à saint germain en
laye
deux invités pour évoquer cette réforme
de l'éducation bertrand mesure bonsoir s
unit pp fsu syndicat enseignant hervé
deux marques directeur de l'école de la
deuxième chance à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines écoles de la
deuxième chance basée à trappes
notamment cet établissement qui est
inséré forme les jeunes adultes de 18 à
25 ans sortis du système scolaire sans
formation et sans qualification ce matin
libération a donc publié une interview
de vincent peillon le ministre de
l'éducation on y apprend plusieurs
points sur la réforme à venir carte
scolaire plus rigide à rythmes scolaires
plus léger elle nous allons élaborer une
nouvelle carte scolaire plus rigide ils
l'affirment et ce afin d'augmenter la
mixité sociale mais aussi scolaire à la
rentrée 2014 une carte scolaire plus
stricte c'est déjà un bon point sur
cette réforme qui sera officiellement
dévoilée début janvier en tout cas ça va
être l'occasion de retravailler un peu
ce qui s'est fait ces dernières années
et qui a poussé à des établissements
ghettos qui petit à petit ont vu partir
leurs meilleurs élèves et c'est vrai que
la mixité dans les cours et quelque
chose qui est absolument indispensable
pour que se mette en place de bonnes
conditions d'apprentissage parce que les
élèves quel que soit leur âge d'ailleurs
n'apprennent pas uniquement avec leurs
professeurs ils apprennent aussi dans la
confrontation qu'ils peuvent avoir avec
leur père
pour vous la mixité c'est une bonne
chose remettent de la mixité je pense
qu'on apprend beaucoup mieux de ses
pairs perrière qu'on ne sait père ter et
c'est une des pédagogique en développe
aussi à l'école de la deuxième chance
donc oui je pense que c'est important la
mixité seulement c'est l'exemple de
l'école de la deuxième chance qui
pourrait inspirer ses différentes ont
raison oui nous on n'a que des jeunes
sans diplôme ni qualification sortis du
système scolaire donc on a une autre
forme de mixité justement on va parler
tout à l'heure des actions que vous
développez que vous menez on va voir si
la réforme de l'éducation pour aib a
limité peut-être le nombre d'entrants
dans votre école au final c'est ce qu'on
peut souhaiter à ces jeunes c'est qu'ils
trouvent rapidement une qualification et
et ne serait-ce qu'un emploi par la
suite je reprécise que la réforme les
points de réformes qui ont été dévoilés
ce matin dans libération ce ne sont que
quelques points la réforme complète sera
véritablement présenté fin janvier en
conseil des ministres et puis ensuite
elle sera présentée au conseil d'état
discuté au parlement fin février début
mars le rythme scolaire ça aussi on en
parle depuis il ya plusieurs semaines
c'est officiel retour des cours le
mercredi matin 2013 dans un premier
temps 2014 pour tout le monde un rythme
scolaire à l'école primaire je vous
demande également de réagir sur cette
mesure là les rythmes scolaires c'était
ça devenait une nécessité depuis que le
samedi matin avait été supprimée les
élèves comme les enseignants étaient
confrontés à une journée extrêmement
copieuse sur un timbre serré l'autre
caractéristique est spécifiquement
française c'est un resserrement sur le
calendrier annuel
force est de constater que pour
l'instant à part la mise en place d'une
demi journée supplémentaire dont on ne
connaît pas encore tout à fait le format
et dont on sur laquelle on peut se poser
pas mal de questions on n'a pas beaucoup
d'éléments ce qui est certain c'est que
l'amplitude journalière devraient être
diminuées mais dans des proportions
relativement restreinte puisque il ya un
temps qui n'est pas encore clairement
identifié et qui sera quand même un
temps de présence pour les élèves et
pour les enseignants donc voilà il ya
encore pas mal de zones d'ombré je
dirais peut-être une certaine
cacophonie entre des ces annonces d'un
côté et puis un calendrier extrêmement
resserré de l'autre côté qui font que
actuellement la plupart des enseignants
sont plutôt dans le flou je pense que
les collectivités locales aussi et un
premier recul tout d'abord au tout début
c'était 2013 pour la mise en place pour
la prochaine rentrée scolaire finalement
ce sera échelonnée sur deux années et
puis il reste à bien définir la façon
dont ça va s'organiser puisque
effectivement les collectivités locales
les villes vont devoir s'organiser aussi
pour accueillir les élèves voilà et déjà
il ya eu un premier élément dans le
calendrier c'est à dire que la prise de
décision qui devait avoir lieu début
février a été repoussée au mois de mars
puisque vous l'évoquez la la loi
d'orientation ne sera pas voté avant fin
venir des plus hauts de mars et qu'il
est indispensable de savoir à partir de
quoi on s'organise
maintenant il semble indispensable du
point de vue des enseignants qu'une
vraie concertation s'engage de façon à
ce que les choses ne soient pas imposées
dans l'urgence beaucoup d'enseignants
sont extrêmement inquiets quant à ce qui
risque de se mettre en place nous avons
connu le samedi matin mais qui était à
un moment particulier la transposition
au mercredi matin n'est pas une simple
transposition d'une demi-journée salle a
des incidences assez lourde sur le la
vider de nos jeunes collègues en
particulier qui ont des enfants et les
choses ne sont pas aussi simple que ça
donne aussi un nouveau rythme pourrait
effectivement il faudra s'en sépara
l'une des conséquences ce sera un
nouveau rythme et ce sera aussi des
engagements financiers supplémentaires
puisqu'elle s'est pour l'instant
effectivement il n'y a pas eu de deux
points très précis sur des rémunérations
ou non des ajustements tout à fait plus
présent en tout cas sur un mode de
fonctionnement très différent voilà si
je prends l'exemple des yvelines où on a
une profession qui est extrêmement
féminisé ou et où donc les collègues
vont avoir le souci de la gare du
mercredi matin et bien et pour l'instant
il n'y a aucune piste vraiment sérieuse
de réflexion autour du sujet même s'il
ministre dans l'interview donnée à
libération justement précisé que la
porte était ouverte aux négociations
avec les syndicats les syndicats qui
semblent prêts à négocier
la table tout à fait et j'ajouterais
encore autre chose c'est que
l'acce qui a été choisie qui est un axe
de simplement d'une refonte de la
semaine scolaire ne prend pas en compte
pour l'instant une réflexion beaucoup
plus globale sur le sens général de
l'école et en particulier sur quel
programme sert que va-t-on faire pendant
ces temps là la caractéristique au sigle
du système éducatif français c'est que
je crois que nous sommes les deuxièmes
en europe en nombre d'heures travaillées
sur l'année donc quelle que soit la
façon dont on envisage les choses
il ya une réflexion à mener sur le temps
passé à l'école et sur ce qu'on y fait
qu'attendez-vous de cette réforme de
l'éducation nous vous avons posé la
question aujourd'hui on se retrouve
ensuite sur le plateau pour continuer
cette discussion si j'attends que tout
le monde sache lire et écrire au 6e
qu'on développe davantage la lecture et
les classiques aussi je pense la classe
le mercredi matin sincèrement je trouve
ça idiot puisque moi je vois j'ai cinq
enfants ils sont fatigués déjà au bout
de deux jours et ça fait du bien d'avoir
une pause dans sa semaine
première raison les réformes ça fait à
peu près la 300e réforme car depuis 20
ans donc
je n'attends rien c'est triste mais
c'est comme ça et deuxième raison qui me
concerne mais qui concerne bien des
enfants c'est que le mercredi matin
souvent et des activités c'est leur
permet de couper avec le rythme scolaire
que depuis le temps qu'il y à des
réformes n'ont jamais rien apporté et
qu'une réforme succèdent aux suivantes
qui réforme la première et c'est donc en
tourner en rond donc en gros les
réformes de serre farias en l'état
actuel des choses il faudrait des
réformes positives qui n'arrivent pas
les gens qui sont finalement assez blasé
on vient de l'entente regarder de marque
le directeur de cette école de la
deuxième chance à saint quentin en
yvelines vous en attendez quoi de la
réforme de l'éducation
nous on est un petit peu
après d'ailleurs vous évoquez le fait
qu'ils aient moins de candidats
potentiels pour les écoles de la même
chance effectivement je pense que c'est
ce que l'on attend mais c'est pas à
titre d' école de la deuxième chance
c'est à titre de citoyen
effectivement si un jour on avait plus
besoin des écoles de la deuxième chance
ça sera une bonne nouvelle pour tout le
monde nous on arriverait c'est vraiment
à faire autre chose il ya cent cinquante
mille jeunes parents qui sortent du
système sans diplôme ni qualification et
qui donc à ce titre sont éligibles aux
écoles de la deuxième chance pour
l'instant la capacité d'accueil du
réseau national parce que les écoles
deuxième chance sont regroupés dans un
réseau de ces en france c'est treize
mille jeunes donc donc voilà si si on
arrive à faire baisser ce chiffre tous
ensemble c'est bien nous on est un petit
peu
le service après formation le service
après écoles mais on vient en
complémentarité de l'éducation nationale
12% 7 en 2011 la part des 18 24 ans qui
ont quitté le système scolaire sans
diplôme ou avec seulement un brevet et
qui ensuite peuvent prétendre à se
rendre dans vos établissements vincent
peillon qui rappelle que le président de
la république a promis de diviser par
deux le nombre de décrocheurs cent
cinquante mille par an ce sont ces
jeunes qui effectivement sont touchés
par le chômage qui n'ont pas de diplôme
vous pensez que concrètement des mesures
peuvent être prises pour permettre de
réduire tout ça bien sûr cette réforme
va le permettre nourry permettra le
premier travail qu'on fait à l'intérieur
des écoles deuxième chance c'est de
travailler sur la confiance
que ces jeunes peuvent avoir eux-mêmes
dans leur propre avenir et dans leurs
propres projets et c'est vrai qu'ils
partagent une certaine forme de de
désespérance je sais qu'aujourd'hui il y
avait aussi les 30 ans des missions
locales ou madame fourneyron autre
ministre intervenait et tout ça c'est
quelque chose qui doit avancer ensemble
on parlait d'une allocation universelle
parce qu'il ya une partie de ces jeunes
qui doivent en même temps trouver une un
système d'insertion professionnelle et
subvenir à leurs propres besoins et ça
devient compliqué il ya des effet ciseau
qui sont redoutables donc oui il ya
beaucoup à faire et il ya du travail
pour pour beaucoup de monde peut
s'intéresser aussi à cette question de
la pédagogie est ce qu'il faut tout
reprendre à l'école nous ont
certainement pas il s'agit pas de tout
reprendre mais il s'agit de se donner du
temps on évoquer enfin les personnes qui
parlait tout à l'heure à évoquer le la
multiplicité des réformes il faut savoir
par exemple le système finlandais qui
souvent cité en exemple c'est un système
qui sait donner une profondeur de 20 ans
pour pour évoluer et les alternances
politiques n'ont pas modifié cette
volonté de faire évoluer le système je
crois que l'école de la république a
besoin de ce temps là parce que
actuellement ce qui en défaut en france
c'est l'école de la première chance
c'est à dire quels moyens peut-on se
donner comment peut-on organiser un
système éducatif qui soit suffisamment
performant pour déjà ne pas maltraiter
les jeunes on évoqué tout à l'heure le
problème de la confiance est quelque
chose qui est récurrent par exemple dans
l'est dans les évaluations qui sont
faits au niveau international les jeunes
français manque de confiance au moment
du lancement en tant qu'enseignant vous
pouvez donner un redonner confiance aux
jeunes qui croient qu'ils participent
qui suivront cours par exemple et bien
comment on peut leur donner confiance
d'abord leur disant que l'école c'est
quelque chose d'important que c'est
quelque chose dans lequel non seulement
on prépare un avenir professionnel mais
avant tout on se prépare soi même à
devenir sujet à devenir citoyen d'une de
la république française je crois que ça
c'est un élément important c'est un
endroit où on va dire aux jeunes que au
travers de la découverte qu'ils font de
l'environnement scolaire immédiat mais
plus généralement de l'environnement
sociétal et bien ils vont prendre une
place dans la société c'est aussi un
endroit où on se découvre une identité
où on la forge où on l'a on l'a comment
dirais-je on l'a peaufinée et où on peut
en être fier tous ces éléments là
malheureusement ont tendance depuis ces
dernières années avoir été pas mal en
difficulté donc c'est cette école là
qu'il faut recréer parce que elle permet
un jeune quand ils sortent du système
éducatif de se sentir intégré dans une
société peut être une autre réalité
aussi 20% des élèves de 15 ans ont de
grandes difficultés à l'écrit ça veut
dire qu'il fait là aussi il faut revoir
les méthodes d'apprentissage au-delà du
fait de redonner confiance en soi à
chacun c'est important mais aussi sur la
façon même d'apprendre les choses alors
les grandes difficultés à l'écrit elles
sont interrogées effectivement mais très
souvent il ya une notion de
catastrophisme qui tend à vouloir dire
que 20% des élèves ne savent pas liés à
l'entrée en sixième c'est pas tout à
fait ça c'est 20 % des élèves qui ne
maîtrise pas les compétences attendues
d'un élève entrant en sixième on est
quand même loin de du qatar tout cas là
on est sur 20% à peu près des élèves de
15 ans qui ont du mal à l'écrit qui ont
du mal à derry bah oui et c'est donc
pour ça qu'il est nécessaire de prendre
le temps de réfléchir
je dirais dès la maternelle à ce que
signifie l'acte d'apprendre à lire et de
se donner le temps de le construire on a
beaucoup charger la barque ces dernières
années sur les programmes dans un
contexte que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
c'est à dire d'une amplitude horaire
annuel qui était extrêmement resserré et
ça n'est peut-être pas très favorable à
un apprentissage
facilité de la langue française par
exemple donc il faudrait se donner les
moyens de construire des programmes qui
permettent de mettre les éléments
essentiels en premier et surtout de ne
pas avoir comme on l'a connu ces
dernières années une inflation de
d'éléments dans les programmes scolaires
qui finissent à terme par nuira au bon
fonctionnement du système pour conclure
je vous ferai réagir sur la question de
la formation également aller forcément
attendu cette refonte de la formation
des enseignants mais juste hervé de
marque par rapport à ces difficultés à
l'écrit vous voulez constater c'est une
réalité pour vous aussi les jeunes qui
se présentent dans vos établissements
dans vos écoles de la deuxième chance
ont beaucoup de difficultés ne serait ce
que pour écrire donc répondre à une
annonce pour un emploi c'est presque
impossible pour eux
d'abord leur première difficulté c'est
qu'il ose pas et donc c'est en forgeant
qu'on devient forgeron et c'est en
écrivant qu'on devient suffisamment bon
comme écrivain la plupart des jeunes
qu'on accueille à l'école de la deuxième
chance et quand je dis la plupart c'est
une immense majorité ont aucunes
difficultés cognitives donc ils ont en
moyenne 20 ans ils sont effectivement
sortis du système scolaire sans diplôme
ni qualification donc ça n'a pas marché
comme il l'aurait souhaité et ils sont
souvent dans un très fort défaut de
l'estiment de même quand on leur demande
de nous citer des qualités c'est des
choses très compliquées et puis ils ont
l'impression d'avoir rien appris à
l'école et alors qu'ils ont appris déjà
pas mal de choses et la première chose
qu'on fait c'est un positionnement alors
qui est pas là pour savoir s'ils vont
pouvoir intégrer l'école ou pas c'est
pour savoir où ils en sont et comme on
est dans une pédagogie individualisée
bas pour qu'il reparte au delà où ils
ont besoin de repartir et ils se rendent
compte à ce moment là que finalement ils
savent faire plein de choses et ils ont
retenu de l'école et c'est pas tous les
élèves c'est qu'une petite partie que
finalement il y avait appris peu de
choses et quand on fait l'inventaire
avec eux ils se rendent compte qu'ils en
ont appris beaucoup plus qu'il imaginait
donc on peut déjà partir de là de ce
côté positif je pense qu'il ya plein de
choses à creuser écoles de la deuxième
chance il en sera question dans quelques
minutes on va juste conclure sur cette
question de la formation dans le cadre
de la réforme de l'éducation donc la
formation des enseignants la loi devrait
créer des écoles supérieures du
professeur et de l'éducation au sein des
universités dès la rentrée 2013 pour
permettre une solide formation
disciplinaire et professionnelle
notamment par le biais de stages
ce qui n'était plus forcément le cas
avant et ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour vous bah oui vous accueillez salé
constat qui a été fait ces deux
dernières années sont catastrophiques
laisser penser qu'on pouvait devenir
professeur simplement en étant mis dans
le bain et puis en ayant une solide
connaissent une solide formation
disciplinaire c'était tout à fait
extravagant et on s'en est bien rendu
compte avec des situations extrêmement
dur vécu par nos jeunes collègues moi je
reviendrai sur ce que disait monsieur
c'est à dire que l'école doit redevenir
l'école de la confiance l'école la
confiance qui doyen entre la nation et
puis le système éducatif qu'elle met en
place la confiance qu'il doit y avoir
entre chaque adulte et chaque jeune qui
arrive dans l'école mais de façon plus
générale qui arrive dans la société et
sans cette confiance qui doit je dirais
nourrir les jeunes générations on ne
peut rien construire merci bertrand
mesure d'être venu sur ce plateau
snuipp-fsu
hervé de marque vous restez en plateau
avec nous nous allons parler de l'école
de la deuxième chance un peu plus en
détail votre établissement en ce qui
concerne la réforme de l'éducation le
texte sera présenté en janvier en
conseil des ministres